don't take life too seriously because
you'll never get out alive it's very
true you know you're never gonna get out
alive so have some fun while you're here
i read that you were actually supposed
to be in college and you moved to l.a
without your parents knowing is that
true i was supposed to be at quantum
university in british columbia canada
and i did go there for 45 minutes
and i said no and i left i moved to los
angeles to get into improv comedy i just
thought i'm gonna go do this thing
and i'm going to give it a year and if
it works great if it doesn't i'll go
back to school get a degree and go so
join the workforce did your parents find
out when they saw you on tv or didn't no
it was about six weeks into my trip in
los angeles and i called them and said
hey i'm you know i'm in los angeles i'm
not in school
my father hung up on me
and then
my mom called me back
and i sort of she was always kind of the
voice of reason and then you know my
father sort of came around i eventually
ran out of money so i just
asked an agency to meet with me and and
i called about 10 of them and then i
finally got my foot in the door with
one really small agency and i
bullshitted them i just said if you send
me out on five auditions i don't care
what they are what they're for i promise
you'll come back with one
somehow i got the fourth one i got i got
a sitcom which was probably still the
best job i've ever had because it was um
the residuals no no nothing do with
money
because it was a live audience it was
like kind of what i wanted to be doing
anyway which was
improv comedy and that kind of stuff was
a live audience that would pour in and
then you know the sitcom world is about
a six or seven or eight month at most
job of a year i mean
you know you you finish your season and
then you're free
so i loved it because i would just go
travel i would go backpacking all over
the world and i would do all these sort
of things i think i really spent that
money that i made wisely at the time i
got to see the world and have
experiences so everything happened to me
sort of in aggregate kind of way it was
very sort of slow
and steady so i'm grateful for that kind
of momentum being very very sort of
snail's pace
as opposed to like a rocket ship because
i've watched so many people in this
industry come and go
in various tragic ways and that's the
thing fame is a weird
animal to deal with i think for anybody
so so you know for me it happened so
slowly that it's sort of like getting
into a bath over the course of a year
you know you're not going to get shocked
by the water be it cold or hot you're
going to you know you're going to just
immerse yourself in a way that's
really really slow so most people aren't
really offered that everything's all or
nothing in hollywood it's
either you're the biggest star they've
ever seen or you're done yeah you know i
somehow found that i got lucky and found
that weird sort of middle ground where i
was able to kind of just slowly build
build my my career when you envisioned
your life as an adult was acting the
thing that you wanted to do or was there
another career at five or six years old
that you thought about no i mean i
always thought i'd end up as in law
enforcement like my family so i uh you
know i didn't i didn't imagine that
acting was a was a way to get out of the
house
it wasn't really like a passion when i
was a kid it was something that i was i
was already doing at home you know to to
to survive so you kind of you know i
noticed when i was a kid making people
laugh was a great self-defense mechanism
it really helped me kind of
navigate my way through my own home it
was a means to an end it was just a way
to get out of the house and you know i
could act i didn't necessarily want to i
just knew i could well what was it like
in high school the fact that you were
doing this acting how did your peers
perceive that i hid it largely in high
school than than i never celebrated it
was something i kind of really tried to
keep as quiet as possible for me high
school was a situation where i fight the
more invisible i was the more kind of
happy i was so i just wanted to get
through that [ __ ] show
and go live my life and a lot of the
stuff i did was uh
was shown in the united states but not
necessarily shown in canada so i could
kind of get away with that you're the
youngest of four brothers including a
couple who became cops my dad was a cop
as well okay so how did you stay alive
as the youngest of four uh
you know you get by in your wits that's
how you do it you don't get by on your
fists so
uh yeah it's kind of a rough household
uh sort of i was less like the youngest
brother but more like a moving target
okay there's a lot of a lot of that
stuff we're all super close now
well how did that experience prepare you
for life you kind of become hyper
perceptive you know you start to really
sort of think about how you're going to
survive so so especially my three older
brothers who were so sort of physical
guys and you know there was just rough
housing like for them was always funny
for me it was like a life-threatening
situation so
you sort of uh you sort of learned to
kind of get by on on using your mind not
your fists so i became kind of hyper
perceptive as a kid and i know that that
contributed in in enormous ways to
the different paths i chose in life you
know particularly show business and that
sort of thing i was able to kind of
constantly mimic people or watch people
and look for tiny signs and big signs of
you know danger
it was tough i was yeah i was a kid i
had a lot of anxiety a lot of different
kind of
phobias and issues that i had to had to
sort of work through and and it took me
a long time to kind of recognize those
things as assets as opposed to
liabilities
i still struggle with those those same
things as challenging
as they are and and you know they
they're also gifts that come with those
things you know and um it's that same
sort of situation where you become kind
of incredibly perceptive in ways in
which you you otherwise wouldn't you
know you're all constantly kind of
sensing you know both real danger and
non-existent danger so you're you know
that's those are things that really
helped me in my work what's the biggest
lesson that you've learned about the
business side of film and acting always
just embrace this idea that you know
nothing because you don't i mean you
know as soon as you think you know
exactly what how it's all gonna go down
or or what audiences are really yearning
for you know they it it you can be
surprised you know so um i love that
edict i like that idea that i i believe
in film
and any endeavor to be a process of
collaboration i think you always have to
listen and always ask for help and the
best leaders are are the people that
hire the best people
um so that's for me that's that's the
thing that i think that's the biggest
lesson i've learned is like you know
just hire the best people you can uh
people that you connect with people that
you love people that you know you can
learn from
i get excited about stuff that's kind of
um you know
inventive i love ingenuity i love
anything that sort of i think is is
interesting i'm not like a
guy that sits around sort of rolling the
dice looking at the stock market and
that kind of thing i don't know anything
anything about that
i wouldn't characterize myself as an
entrepreneur i would characterize myself
as someone who
has found a couple of different things
in life that i believed in with every
cell in my body and this is one of them
in thinking about your future what's
important to you
family 100 as anyone will know it's
almost frustratingly so for some of the
people i work with is that i gotta make
sure that my time with my family is
prioritized over anything else
you did something really incredible a
few years ago where you ran the new york
marathon to raise money for the michael
j fox foundation for research for
parkinson's why was that important for
you to do that my father had parkinson's
he died a few years ago but you know my
father is very very proud man i mean i
think he said the word parkinson's to me
maybe twice in his
25 years that he had the disease
so i think more people talk about it the
more i see guys like my father who is a
sort of the archetypal strong man the
guy who you know don't talk about your
feelings cram them down and sort of
robbed of his physicality and he was
strong he's an ex-boxer or cop you know
i think part of his identity was that he
was a very strong man so it forced him
to kind of reassess all those things
which was in a way a good thing
but uh in the end you know that loss of
of of self not quite knowing um uh where
you stand in any given moment
is pretty tough so
i wonder if some of those
underlying ideas or reasons we do get
sick or sick or because we're not sort
of expressing ourselves or letting
things out